yeah yeah movie yeah because we did
we've been traveling i think for like
how long have you guys been traveling
because i've been traveling for almost
three months i don't really count the
week i was back i was traveling
i get it you've been traveling
for a little over two months
i think i was just under two months yeah
by the way it's way too long yeah
cause one thing i think i've realized is
that we tried to like
like test a lot of little things to see
if this tour would be possible one thing
was this intense travel schedule that we
had over the past three months to be
like can we do this without going insane
well it definitely [ __ ] burnt not
burned me up but it definitely took a
toll but it didn't make me go insane
that's a good thing and also we did we
announced the road trip special as well
oh yes yeah yes so we have spent a week
an intensive week with each other in the
same car yeah that was a lot that that
was a lot yeah that sure was like nine
days was it that was including travel
was 10 days yeah 10 10 whole days oh
yeah well i mean that'll be out by the
end of october yeah that'll be fun yes
and uh it should be a big boy long
special that would be a big boy long
special so we've already got a big name
that's what the ladies calling
so we've already got a taste of what
it's like to be with these boys for like
10 days mm-hmm not being able to go
anywhere that was worse though because
the car was tiny that's true at least
the bus we can you know walk around yeah
we have at least our own private
quarters but yeah i guess we should talk
about the special after it's come out
yeah
just look forward to it yeah it's gonna
be a good one yeah i'm i'm hoping that
my car sickness is better on a bus it is
all right
on a bus definitely yeah right right
because you're in a [ __ ] freight
train equivalent of a car
because when you're in a tiny car the
back of the car gets [ __ ] with
suspension yeah yeah
like it's you you get like thrown around
but on a boss it's so big did you get
motion sickness on a train
no
i remember on the road trip there was
like a lot of downtime in the car and i
was like i could read manga or watch
anime or play games and i like got read
one chapter of a manga and i'm like okay
yeah can't do that and basically it was
just a lot of a lot of me just listening
to [ __ ] music and uh just dulling out
pretty much i wish i could do more and i
think that's why it felt so exhausting
because i wanted to do more stuff on the
car just to like chill out but i
hopefully can do that on the tour bus
there's like communal space there's like
tables and stuff in the car it's like
whatever can fit in your lap is
technically the table yep so that that
also makes you just not want to work or
do anything you're like i just i'm not
comfortable this is awful same thing on
a plane right yeah yeah it's like an
economy where you're like i'm gonna work
and then you'll realize your laptop
doesn't even open up fully yeah like
because you can't even like actually get
90 degrees because the chest especially
if the chair in front of you is leaned
all the way back it's just like yeah
yeah oh dude
i've got to say the worst flight i've
ever been on was the was the la to miami
flight at like
the economy flight yeah it was [ __ ]
awful yeah because like the moment the
flight hadn't even taken off and you
know you can't even like move sorry we
went on like a a detour here no no no no
no no no no no no
welcome back to trash days yeah so
actually run like a billion flights yeah
and so we got the red-eye flight from la
to miami and normally when you're on a
flight people wait until the plane is
like in the air and the seat belt things
got off before they recline no not on
this flight it was just like immediately
sat down dude full reclined and i was
like oh this is going to be there like
this all right okay i saw i saw people
as they were walking up to their seats
just grabbing the back of the seat
reclining it back and then sitting yeah
just like chill
we have six hours on this flight you can
do it whenever oh it's a red-eye flight
right yeah i assume people were just
like these were seasoned veterans
i'm ready to sleep yeah i've never been
on a flight before where people like
everyone was calling right before the
moment of takeoff and the moment the
plane touched the ground not even like a
taxi or anything everyone's whipped out
their phones started making calls and i
was like what the [ __ ] is this
i didn't even notice that did you notice
that no because we landed in miami at
like [ __ ] 5 30 in the morning i'm
just like struggling to open my eyes so
i just couldn't [ __ ] see anything
yeah i don't know if i'm the dumb one i
probably am um but i don't like stand up
right away when the plane takes the
plane lands and in america bro it was
like a summoning salt video people were
trying to like clip through the chairs
trying to get their luggage out right
away they'd be like holding their
luggage like this just to stand up for
like 10 minutes standing up on the first
available frame
i'm sitting on the end and i can tell
this guy next to me is visibly getting
annoyed that i'm not standing up right
yeah because we're in the back yeah
we're not going anywhere yeah yeah we
literally are lashed to get on the only
reason i would stand up in a situation
like that is if my knees are killing me
which they were on that flight because
the seats were [ __ ] tiny so i was
just like i just need to [ __ ] stretch
out my legs yeah so then i'll stand up
for a bit you know maybe you know do
some exercise a little bit but then i'll
just yeah i don't know if i'm missing
something like i don't know why people
stand up right away when there's
because maybe they think they can just
like quickly [ __ ] go to the front
yeah if you're in a rush and you have a
connection i can kind of understand the
the you know the impatience but even
then it's like max you save a minute max
yeah yeah because you've got to wait
until the doors open anyway so you're
gonna be standing up for like a good
five ten minutes right yeah that like
again that it's like you even if you
stand up first and you're in the front
you're still not getting off until they
open the goddamn doors like i get that
you want to get ready but you you know
when you can see the crowd moving you
know it makes sense if you're in like
premium economy and you're at the front
of them yeah yeah yeah because you also
have room then as well
[Music]
because like in in economy you can see
where the line goes and people go in
order anyway yeah right because
even if you're sitting down
you know there's there's an order to
this there's an order to this chaos
otherwise there isn't an [ __ ] like 10
seats back being like out of the way out
of the way whatever you can't like
a fight would happen yeah yeah but even
every it doesn't matter where i've gone
in the world everyone every country does
this yeah i don't know why there's just
people on the plane that stand up
immediately and they're like i'm getting
off first and then max they save 10
seconds
and i mean if it's just purely uh my
legs hurt i want to stand up all right
it's totally fine i get that but you can
tell who the the flight veterans are
because they're the ones who usually
just remain seated
i'm lazy as [ __ ] i'm i'm if i have 10
minutes left on my my netflix thing i'm
watching that until i get kicked off
what does make sense is when people do
this on international flights right
because you get up you save your 10
seconds you're like [ __ ] yes i've saved
10 seconds you've got to wait [ __ ]
half an hour to get your bags anyway
yeah it doesn't make any difference
you're going to be leaving the airport
at the same time anyway that is true and
like customs as well you don't know how
long that's going to be i i honestly
just do it at a pure instinct
like i don't even end up yeah i don't
even i don't know it's like monkey see
monkey dude
the moment the sign is gone i'm like
permission
to just stand up immediately yeah i
don't know i don't even think about it
anymore i think i think for me for the
most part it's i do it again not to
because i want to get out of the plane
quickly which i do but i know i'm not
realistically going to for me it's just
i need to stretch my legs that's fair
enough
because like because if it's because if
i know it's taking a while then yeah
because i just go stretch my legs
because if i know it's taking a while
i'll just sit back down yeah yeah yeah
you're like ah that's too early i was
like oh damn i'm missing okay i will say
that on that one flight it had one thing
that i've never seen before and i think
that every fight should have this from
now on
so right where the tv normally was uh
there's no tv on this on this flight but
like you know where it is right yeah
yeah so they had this thing that popped
out and it was a phone holder oh yeah so
it would it would have your phone you
could just put your phone or ipad in
this thing and it would just be like i
love okay yeah because i was about to
complain about one thing in every flight
which is uh now that we've flown so many
times within the past few months i've
basically seen every every movie i want
to see unlike the flights right i know i
know the [ __ ] catalogue i know the
library okay that is the most first
world problem ever
no it's just like someone when you're
traveling for business there's no
entertainment left when when you've just
watched everything okay look i've look
there's only so many times i can see the
entire library of harry potter on there
and that one episode of [ __ ] hbo show
you know like i've i've wanted to load
up my own season three episode four yeah
yeah well on unlike some flights where
you have to like
so like when you have to load up on your
phone or an ipad or something you're
like oh this is a great idea i can just
watch what i want but unfortunately the
[ __ ] tray tables that come out means
that you have to like watch it like like
yeah yeah
or you just put your phone flat on the
table and you just watch it like this
both are horrible for your neck yeah
exactly and i i finished that [ __ ]
plane at that plane flight with a
[ __ ] 80 year old neck and i have to
like
you know
you know that's i definitely need to
visit our chiropractor afterwards
because you just [ __ ] your neck up you
cannot [ __ ] get off the plane
okay actually actually actually actually
actually question question what is your
guys's sleeping like
what is your sleeping position on a
plane
like what do what is how how does normal
position uh are we talking like unlike
an economy
oh bro i i look like i'm about to like
die
i i like i like kneel over like i put my
head but like between my legs if i can i
saw you doing that on the on the florida
flag like how the [ __ ] is he sleeping
like that i tried to because like i
i thought you were throwing up no no no
no like because for me
i don't know why i just i i cannot sleep
sitting up right i need to feel like my
head is resting on something like this
or like yeah this i don't know no i'm
the same though maybe it's like the
pressure on my head kind of makes me i
don't know why no i'm the same i need to
feel like like i'm leaning on either
side of my face so what i do is i take
the you know the seat at the back like
the cushion thing most of those cushion
things you can kind of fold the edges
yeah yeah like that so what i do is i do
that and then i kind of yeah it doesn't
doesn't work
that doesn't work but that's the best
we've got
i gotta work with a lot of god guys
the reason i ask is because i don't know
what it is about planes where any other
form of transportation you there's
enough room to get like a decent decent
sleeping position i think
i'm like i'm i think i'm like wider than
you
so like
like you call yourself dummy thing
my frame is just larger like you're
taller but i have like a wider frame i
swear that's like it sucks because if
you're tall you can just like origami
yourself into a position or right you're
wide you're like
my arms are gigantic right [ __ ] giant
biceps right obviously you're not
[ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger
i i i got a dummy think ass right
now because i i have i have this dilemma
right of like i need something to i need
to be leaning my face like the sides of
my face on something to get even just
like
a tiny amount of sleep yeah so then you
might be thinking well joey just sit on
the window seat because then you can
just lean against the wall no that
doesn't work my problem is that that
works except i have the bladder the size
of a peanut and so i have to get up
every like hour or two to go to pee and
so i need to sit on at least the aisle
seat because otherwise i just feel
[ __ ] horrible for the two other
people i'm sitting next to right so now
i'm stuck in this dilemma of like do i
prioritize my bladder or do i prioritize
my sleep and most of the time i just
prioritize my bladder so i just have to
[ __ ] deal with this thing yeah see my
my plain sleep nerf because everyone has
a plain sleep nerf like a condition that
has to be met
um is that my head needs to be like
beyond 45 degrees otherwise it doesn't
feel like i'm actually like sleeping
right so when when i see people sleeping
next to the window with their with their
heads on the window like i literally
cannot get my head at a like a cute
enough angle to like trick my brain into
thinking i'm going to understand that i
think that's why i like leaning forward
like for me i think it's certainly about
like the pressure on my head or like the
way that i don't know how the blood's
flowing yeah it makes me like it like
recreates how i sleep
we're basically going to like a coma
patient you just
yeah
so the reason why i choose the aisle or
the window and i don't go for the middle
is because on the on the middle one the
only place you can put your head why are
you laughing so much
i am a comatose patient
just imagine the one time like if conor
ever gets into like a plane crash and
the pilot goes everyone regretted your
brace position
connor can literally fall asleep and
he'll be in the brace position all right
i fall asleep in the race position okay
that's right
it's comfortable it makes sense the
reason why you're bracing it
so
as i was saying before godly
wake up wait never mind
you're good
okay
okay
i
lean
and if i lean in the middle i can only
go straight and my head will hit the
chair yeah and i can't get my head into
the position i want because it's too
close yeah because i i can't just get it
in enough and it'll like push against my
neck yeah if i if i do
so i have to do the window because the
window the thing that they're down by
the window right is that uh there's a
little gap between the window and the
chair yeah yeah yeah so i put my head in
that little crevice
so as long as the guy behind me doesn't
randomly like try to tickle my head i'm
good and i do the same thing on the
aisle but the problem is if you do on
the island's risky because if they bring
the car they wake you up
leave my head there so
yeah it's a gamble yeah no when i when i
said i when i said i lean on the window
i obviously meant that the crack between
the window and the seat belt so you're
going forward so same
everyone who sits in front of connor
gets them gets a it gets a viewing of
the shining yeah
it pretty much imagines it looks like
that yeah i just thought they didn't
turn around
how often are you looking in that
[ __ ] crevice behind you well you know
if you might you know because sometimes
if you're sitting on the window seat the
window can be positioned a little bit
far back than what is normal so you know
what if your window is like back here
and then you just look good
if you're being a little embarrassed and
having a good sleep i'll tell you i'll
take i'll take this how the [ __ ] do you
sleep like that again i don't know i
have to wouldn't it make more sense to
do it on the back side i can't like i
can't sleep lying down like like face uh
back down yeah and so
reclining the chair is just a beta
version wait how do you sleep normally
uh on my sides oh so you can't sleep on
your back i i i sleep no i've never been
able to sleep in my bed really so i
sleep on my side but like i want to say
if it's my side but my body is very much
leaning towards my stomach facing the
bed all right right kind of like
because there's some times where i can't
go
yeah because i've tried and that's where
like being tall is enough because i can
never like i can never get my body into
enough of a position where because when
when i try to lean forward yeah this is
like the this is like the most forward i
can go right i can't even get close like
the traitor even
when all right even when say for example
you do have enough space to just be able
to squeeze in to lie on the tray table
yeah my back just [ __ ] no i don't i
don't like my tray table around my knees
that's even further down yeah doesn't
that [ __ ] you back up ah maybe
i sleep so
[ __ ] hell your knees yeah jesus
christ
i put my arms on my knees as a pillow
i'm i feel i'm trying to i'm trying to
remember i feel more worried about your
back
no that would kill me
the end of your knees you're on your
thighs
i don't think i can even do this because
i've i've i have a couple of friends who
have slept like
just like that no my back
position my back would
just the permanent shinji
yeah the coma the cop was risky because
like you
you're rash putting your head in like
the crevice and you're relying on the
crevice right right and you know if
they're playing shakes it's not as not
as bouncy as your bones right the shinji
strat is only open to those on the 510
yeah it's just it's locked for us it's
locked i've brutally discovered that the
american airlines uh chairs are really
[ __ ] close together compared to like
because i've done it a bunch in japan on
the domestic a a flight and i noticed
you we have way more room on those
domestic economies right right than the
american airlines one that was [ __ ]
close those american airline flights are
so goddamn compact yeah yeah i'm not
[ __ ] around yeah any closer and i'd
be kissing the person in front of me
yeah
yeah
hope you're having a good flight
[Laughter]